THAT IS YOUR JOB.
AND TONIGHT MY NEXT GUEST
BELIEVES THE ONGOING
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE WAS
NEVER ABOUT REMOVING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM OFFICE.
INSTEAD IT WAS DESIGNED AS A
TOOL TO HURT REPUBLICAN
SENATORS IN BLUE AND PURPLE
STATES.
THIS IS GUY THAT HAS NEVER
LOST A CASE AS A PROSECUTOR
IN HIS LIFE.
PRETTY SMART GUY.
HE IS ALSO -- ARE YOU NOW
BACK OFFICIALLY AS A FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
DID WE PUT THE CAMERA BACK
THE WAY IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE?
TREY GOWDY IS WITH US.
>> EVERYTHING IS GREAT AND
I'M THRILLED TO BE BACK.
>> Sean: I DIDN'T ASK IF
EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
DID THEY TAKE CARE OF YOU
AND RESIGN YOU.
I'M FIGHTING FOR TREY GOWDY
TO BE A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
>> YES, SIR, THEY HAVE BEEN
FANTASTIC.
THEY HAVE BEEN GREAT.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: YOU GAVE A LOT OF
GREAT STATEMENTS.
I KNOW THIS IS YOUR WHEEL
HOUSE.
TELL US WHY THIS IS SO
CORRUPT.
>> LET'S SKIP OVER THE
PROCESS.
THREE MONTH LONG
INVESTIGATION WAS LAUGHABLE.
BUT THEY VOTED.
THAT'S THE HOUSE'S
PREROGATIVE.
THEY VOTED NOT A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN WENT ALONG WITH
THEM.
IN FACT, THEY DIDN'T EVEN
KEEP ALL THE DEMOCRATS.
BUT THE HOUSE EXERCISED ITS
PREROGATIVE AND THEY
INTEECHED THE
IMTEECHED THE
IMPEECHED THE
IMPEACHED THE PRESIDENT.
THERE IS NO MATHEMATICAL WAY
HE IS EVER GOING TO BE
CONVICTED.
AND THEY KNOW THAT.
SO THEIR GOAL CANNOT BE TO
REMOVE DONALD TRUMP FROM
OFFICE.
IT IS TO NEUTER HIS SECOND
TERM.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO WIN
IN NOVEMBER.
IT'S TO NEUTER THAT SECOND
TERM BY TARGETING THE CORY
GARDNERS AND MARTHA
MCSALLYS AND THOM TILLISS
AND JONI ERNST BECAUSE IF
TRUMP WINS AND DOESN'T HAVE
THE SENATE.
THEN HE IS NOT GOING TO GET
ANY JUDICIAL VACANCIES
FILLED AND NOT REPLACE A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE IF HE
OR SHE RETIRES.
IS HE NOT GOING TO GET THE
FOREIGN POLICY HE WANTS.
HE IS NOT GOING TO GET THE
CABINET HE WANTS.
I NEVER THOUGHT THIS WAS
ABOUT REMOVING DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
DO IT.
IT'S ABOUT PUTTING CORY
GARDNER IN A REALLY TOUGH
SERIES OF VOTES SO HE HAS TO
DEFEND HIM IN NOVEMBER OF
THIS FALL.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT THROUGH THE PRISM OF
POLITICS 299 DAYS TO GO
UNTIL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
GET TO MAKE THE FINAL
DECISION.
IT'S UP TO THEM AND THEY CAN
SHOCK THE WORLD AGAIN AND I
HOPE TREY GOWDY IN FACT THAT
THAT HAPPENS.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS QUESTION
AND IT'S A LEGAL ONE
CONSTITUTIONALLY THE SOLE
ROLE OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES TO IMPEACH.
IS IT THE SOLE ROLE OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES TO
PUT THE TRIAL ON.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT HE PRO-SIDES.
NOW THE HOUSE MANAGERS WILL
PRESENT THEIR CASE.
NOW, THEY ARE TRYING TO HAVE
A REDO AND GET THE SENATE TO
DO THE JOB THAT THEY
COULDN'T DO IN THE HOUSE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL
REPUBLICAN SENATORS TONIGHT?
>> SAME THING I TOLD THEM IN
THE OP-ED.
IF HE THINKS THE TESTIMONY
OF JOHN BOLTON IS SO
INCIDENCE SPENCE CYBIL
INDIDENCE SPENCE CYBIL
INDISPNCE SPENCE CYBIL
INDISPENE SPENCE CYBIL
INDISPENSASPENCE CYBIL
INDISPENSABLENCE CYBIL
INDISPENSABLE TE CYBIL
INDISPENSABLE THECYBIL
INDISPENSABLE THENYBIL
INDISPENSABLE THEN TIL
INDISPENSABLE THEN THEY
SHOULD HAVE SUBPOENAED HIM.
IT'S NOT TO INVESTIGATE AND
THEN DELIBERATE.
IF THAT WERE TRUE WE
WOULDN'T NEED THE HOUSE.
SCHIFF WAS IN SUCH A HURRY.
KEEP IN MIND, SEAN, ALL YOUR
VIEWERS HAVE TO GO TO COURT
IF THEY HAVE A DISAGREEMENT
WITH A FELLOW CITIZEN.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAD TO GO
TO COURT TO GET DOCUMENTS IN
FAST AND FURIOUS.
WE HAD TO GO FIGHT ADAM
SCHIFF IN COURT TO FIND OUT
WHO FUNDED THE DOSSIER.
WE ALL KNOW HOW TO GET TO
THE COURTHOUSE.
SCHIFF DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO
COURT.
HE WANTS THE SENATE TO CALL
THE VERY WITNESSES THAT HE
DIDN'T HAVE THE COURAGE TO
CALL HIMSELF.
AND THAT'S NOT THEIR JOB.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE
SENATORS THAT I TALKED TO ON
A REGULAR BASIS UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF MITCH
MCCONNELL ARE NOT FALLING
FOR NANCY PELOSI'S TRICK.
SHE CAN SEND THEM AND THEY
DUAL WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY ARE NOT MOVED BY THIS
THREE-WEEK PAUSE THAT SHE
HAS ENGAGED IN.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
TREY GOWDY.